how's it going rest my name is Peter
path by the [ __ ] are we doing chair
you're here with me good I don't like
this I really really don't like this
just take it easy one step at a time
I got sharing my [ __ ] hate the noises
ha ha I'm not gonna play from there nope
I'm sorry I don't [ __ ] games [ __ ]
terrifying
alright I need a chair as thing is for
Simon it's checkmate man let's follow
the light this time Oh
I thought that [ __ ] line would say
what you want but ah [ __ ] you oh it's
[ __ ] out there it is [ __ ] out
there what is what in the hell what a
nerve
what I didn't even know what's going on
here I really really really really
really really really read what that
[ __ ] you know what what do you know
what stop stop I don't want to hug you
get off man
are you pathetic can I use system oh you
can't go in here they can't go in here
you [ __ ] open the door let's get the
[ __ ] out of it I literally don't have
any [ __ ] left sick because this [ __ ]
[ __ ] Oh baby
oh there's a refrigerator here I don't
[ __ ] know what I was supposed to do
why is it red over here
it's a lap all right we need a plan
light is not here let's wait for the
light [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
that's right mr. smoke [ __ ] here we go
again back to square nah Madonna oh [ __ ]
genj place
no John change tomorrow me mr.brother
beta they can tell with my poor little
buddy okay we're going what the [ __ ] is
that
let's go there what's up
I don't [ __ ] dryer coca-cola groceries
don't tell me all the light is coming
here I think but we are here jabbers
absurd snacks vanilla Drake I love that
[ __ ] I don't feel safe here
can the light please come over here no
light a like a
he's right [ __ ] there I'm saving I'm
saving I'm waiting father I'm sorry
sorry running running Oh
regretting rewriting rewriting rewriting
opening closing egg ah not dear please
vital signs critical la plante please
ignore what you just wait this it's
normal okay family know where the
[ __ ] he can come in a little and then
he dies
well I'm gonna [ __ ] here while the
refrigerator makes me warm [ __ ] you
you can't touch me [ __ ] lamb what have
you been
that's right hey glom hey lamb no hey
babes okay
oh there you are laughs I'm sorry I
thought you died well this is quite the
pickle AVR huh Alamo huh question is if
I can crouch myself through here huh I
can I can't
what was that
what is the plan here
it's weird how it doesn't have any any
other ambience in this and it's so
[ __ ] scary how do I move you how do I
move yo how do I move y'all how do i oh
I feel good def is good
I peed a little but it's okay hey it's
normal
grown man pee hi everyone P clearly
everyone I don't know if insects pee I
never really investigated I know insects
poo
I seen worms poo it was kind of gross he
might have just been digging though and
I think about it it could be dirt but I
like to imagine that it was poo because
it was brown I don't know what I like to
imagine Brown fingers poop
I don't think is that we're not that
we're I don't I don't really know they
could urinate a little bit and you
wouldn't even know it okay here we go
I'm a Luke station map alright we are
here in the main building cheerio and we
went day uh-huh I'm sitting out quite
certain if I know exactly when I am but
let's keep going
I'm just how [ __ ] her I'm blowing
alright let's not do anything stupid
here that's tonight alright we need to
think where we are supposed to go
because we are exiting here I guess
Ryder then it turns out I should have
made a left turn here so let's do that
why my prolonged exposure should right
away
ah don't think I can see you out there
you little [ __ ] you [ __ ] barrel
how do you do not freeze to death why am
I supposed to breathe for that it's not
fair it's not fair I say alright kennels
it's stuck I'll use this [ __ ] how about
that
merica simple enough I knew that because
I change it what is that it's it's it's
sexy hello yeah tongue out and
everything
this penumbra overture barrel what I do
know what did you do here mom
you [ __ ] owe your [ __ ] every round
yeah
alright so uh is this a swimming pool
it's frozen just like everything else
huh what is he doing I asked fliers I
want them yes I do want those if I'm
gonna go in here nope we're not gonna
we're not going that no sir no sir
I want those flowers I Platt place open
there we go hello gentlemen I hope you
don't mind me taking one of these that's
okay right I'm gonna assume that's a yes
all right
for lady gaga
ah da da all right [ __ ] this [ __ ]
what are we going it's [ __ ] brows sad
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no I'm
sorry I'm sorry I can change I could job
like a change
oh no that did not go as planned you
it's your fault okay it's my fault sorry
sorry
I didn't think the flower would run out
so quickly can I chill with you guys
what's up what's your name
Rudolph okay cool what's your name
Lassie it doesn't even have a face
that's disgusting what's that why would
you do that why would you impale a
little Snoop Dogg that's me I need this
harpoon I could fight evil with it right
bass okay let's just do this again let's
save a little here I'll take you for you
Amy all the veg body fat doc stop sorry
alright what happens up here
my god I'm a genius my god get up get up
get up get up and [ __ ] no no you can't
reach me up here it's a little [ __ ] I
don't know what what are you
the [ __ ] are you I wish I still had my
flower
that's really [ __ ] dark don't get my
place
I don't care they okay progress
excelencia that sounds like a hmm
mr. share what happen here
ah just calm down you can't open doors
that is a fine lady with a drug spill
I'm a harmonica isn't that it no we are
even fact indeed at Greenland all right
let me touch this no I'm not I what what
just everything this goes by so fast
shaukat list snow catalyst ignition key
probably in longing I remember lodge was
lending it to somebody
uh-huh navigation map biodiesels snow
cats only runs on biodiesel all right so
we need that an entire link got it so we
need need these things to get the [ __ ]
out of here I would assume a black snow
infection last three days it can read
that if you want I don't think most of
you want me to actually read it
so he's been calling your Mac heart it's
a wonderful name by the way
well I like this computer stuff it's a
very detailed mod I'm thoroughly
enjoying it aren't you box aren't you
enjoying it don't you enjoy that aren't
you enjoying at that's right box
you better [ __ ] enjoy all right mr.
chef seriously stand up thank you
the [ __ ] was that
and coming out now you better not [ __ ]
with me cuz I will [ __ ] with you alright
we just need the fuel and then we can
get the [ __ ] out of here we parked it
nicely we can drink to the lady what's
up how in the heavens well that was
probably step one oh this properly
failed me so much let's go we're back
and this [ __ ] snow and the next
episode like a village enjoyed this guy
come over today and I'll see you next
episode of ever make a biro
I'm an ultimate voice again where your
level of requests for people are money
running down your street plan boss all
this after 30 seconds at the time
however with power prayer still it's
pretty [ __ ] messy so enjoy yes if you
kill this guy without me I
the dilemma